ich bin ich klare sache aber was macht
mich wirklich aus was passiert zum
beispiel wenn mein gehirn exakt kopiert
wird und mein originales gehirn dadurch
ersetzt
wenn ich dann immer noch ich bin
christoph krachten und das ist krieg zum
salzen
das ist eines der konzepte die man als
kind als erstes begreift aber wenn man
mal darüber nachdenkt was es wirklich
bedeutet jemand zu sein dann kann man
schon ordentlich ins grübeln kommen was
also macht uns wirklich aus am
sinnvollsten wäre es mit dem anzufangen
was die meisten anderen menschen mit uns
verbinden unserem körper wenn der körper
stirbt dann sterben wir auch obwohl wir
uns gerne einreden dass wir mehr sind
am ende des tages bestehen wir auch nur
aus fleisch und knochen aber wie viel
von unserem körper können wir entfernen
bis wir nicht mehr wir sind haare und
fingernägel schneiden ändern nichts
daran
wer wir sind und auch nach einer
schönheits-op sind wir dieselben
menschen auch wenn sich die äußere
erscheinung geändert hat aber was
passiert wenn wir unser gehirn mit
jemand anderem tauschen würden wer ist
dann das wahre ich obwohl unser körper
so rumläuft wie immer und sogar unsere
familie unseren alten körper
wiedererkennt sind doch unsere gedanken
unsere erfahrung hoffnung und ängste
alles was uns wirklich ausmacht in einem
wildfremden körper sie sind in unserem
gehirn das transplantiert wurde
also stellen wir eine theorie auf unser
gehirn ist wer wir wirklich sind und wir
sind da wo unser gehirn ist aber was ist
wenn jemand folgendes macht beim gehirn
tausch werden sich zwei gehirn
ausgetauscht sondern nur die daten die
das gehirn speichert beide gehirne
werden gescannt die daten gespeichert
und danach komplett gelöscht
dann werden die daten auf das jeweils
andere gehirn aufgespielt jetzt wäre
mein gehirn wie immer in meinem körper
aber irgendein typ rennt jetzt mit
meinem körper und meinem gehirn rum
ich bin mit meinen gedanken wieder in
einem anderen körper was uns ausmacht
ist demnach nicht unser physikalisches
gehirn sondern unsere erinnerung und
unsere persönlichkeit
alles was auf dem gehirn gespeichert ist
um diese neue theorie die daten theorie
zu testen machen wir einen zeitsprung
300 jahre in die zukunft die menschheit
hat inzwischen das beamen erfunden
ich wohne im futuristischen köln arbeite
aber in berlin
morgens gehe ich in einen
tiertransporter dort werde ich gescannt
jedes molekül
jedes einzelne atom wird genau
aufgezeichnet mit position und
ausrichtung die daten werden nach berlin
übermittelt wo mein körper genauso
zusammengesetzt wird wie er gescannt
wurde
danach werden die atome in köln zerstört
ich sehe also kurz schwarz und geht dann
in berlin gemütlich aus dem transporter
ich habe noch den selben gedanken dank
wie gerade in knapp 600 kilometer
entfernten köln
und ich habe immer noch hunger aber
eines tages passiert etwas seltsames der
zerstörer der meine alten atome nach dem
scannen zerstören soll funktioniert
nicht der rest der apparatur aber schon
ich werde in köln aus dem teleporter
gezogen laut den gesetzen der zukunft
muss man körper nun zerstört werden denn
schließlich laufe ich ja gerade in
berlin rom wo meine zellen sowie immer
zusammen gebaut worden
ganz normal mit meinen gedanken und
meinen erinnerungen oder wer ist diese
person die da in berlin rumläuft
schließlich ist mein bewusstsein immer
noch hier in köln wo es auch vorher
schon war
und selbst wenn dort irgendeine exakte
kopie von mir herum läuft ist sie sicher
nicht ich denn ich bin ja immer noch
hier in köln wir wissen wie wir also
katzen affen ich muss hier arbeiten also
wir stoßen hier auf ein weiteres großes
problem eine exakte kopie von mir ist
nichtig auch wenn jeder meiner gedanken
und jede erfahrung im kopf des klons zu
sein scheint so sind es doch nicht die
originalen gedanken und erinnerungen
mein bewusstsein ist immer noch im
selben körper das original hat sich
nicht bewegt noch interessanter wird es
wenn wir den teleporter der zukunft
etwas umbauen
jetzt schickt er die daten nicht mehr
nach berlin sondern zerstört mich
einfach nur noch und baut mich mit
denselben atomen kurz danach wieder
zusammen ich würde rein und rausgehen zu
100 derselbe mensch der aus denselben
atom besteht und die gleichen gedanken
hat wie der mensch der in den teleporter
eingestiegen ist
aber trotzdem bin ich ja da drin
gestorben oder und was auch immer danach
passiert bin ich echt oder doch immerhin
sind menschen mit herzstillstand die
wiederbelebt wurden immer noch die
gleichen menschen aber effektiv ist
gerade nichts anderes passiert als
vorher als die daten nach berlin
geschickt wurden denn auf atomarer ebene
unterscheiden sich die moleküle aus
denen ich bestehe
und die bau moleküle des teleporter in
berlin überhaupt nicht die daten theorie
liefert uns also auch keine genauen
anhaltspunkte darüber wer wir wirklich
sind ein interessanter fakt über den
menschen ist dass er mit nur einer
gehirnhälfte leben kann häufiger als man
glaubt werden op s durchgeführt bei
denen eine gehirnhälfte entfernt wird um
menschen mit extrem häufigen anfällen zu
behandeln mit einer erfolgsrate von 86
prozent
wird die krankheit geheilt diese
menschen haben zwar oft nicht dieselben
fähigkeiten wie menschen mit beiden
gehirnhälften allerdings entwickeln sich
ihre persönlichkeiten und ihr
erinnerungsvermögen erstaunlich normal
was passiert also wenn mir einer meiner
gehirnhälften herausgenommen und in
einen anderen körper gepflanzt wird bin
ich dann auch die person in dem anderen
körper wer ist das original und wo geht
mein bewusstsein hin obwohl beide von
uns meine gedanken und erinnerungen
haben könnte man sowohl behaupten dass
keiner von beiden ich ist oder alle
beide sind ich so langsam wird es
wirklich kopfzerbrechen
aber lasst uns noch eine schippe
drauflegen die menschheit hat im jahr
2003 115 zufällig auch ein gerät
erfunden mit dem ich die zelle meines
körpers einzeln zerstören und durch
andere ersetzen kann
wenn ich jetzt einen finger zerstöre und
durch die gleichen atome ersetze
dann ist der finger danach genau der
gleiche wie vorher und ich bin ja auch
noch ich aber was passiert wenn man
schritt für schritt alle atome meines
körpers komplett durch andere ersetzt im
endeffekt wäre das genau wie der
teleporter der mich zerstört und wieder
zusammenbaut nur das alles stück für
stück passiert
an welcher stelle genau bin ich also
nicht mehr ich wenn ich ein prozent
meines körpers ersetzt habe 19 prozent
oder erst bei 99 prozent
das wirklich krasse ist genau das
passiert jeden tag unsere zellen sterben
ständig ab und werden durch neue ersetzt
das ist normale biologie die baustoffe
dafür bekommen wir durch das essen das
wir essen und die luft die wir atmen und
trotzdem würde jeder von uns behaupten
dass wir vor fünf jahren noch dieselbe
person waren wie heute oder klar sieht
man jetzt etwas anders aus hat
vielleicht neue lieblingsband und
andere frisur und haarfarbe aber man ist
doch immer noch dieselbe person
und jetzt setzt sich noch einen drauf
manche wissen dass mein bruder letztes
jahr gestorben ist sanieren waren krank
zerstört er musste dreimal in der woche
an die blutwäsche dialyse locker hätte
man ihm eine neue niere von einem toten
transplantieren können doch das wollte
er nicht er wollte lieber sterben
warum der grund ist verblüffend und
erschreckend zugleich
nahezu alle transplantierten berichten
von veränderungen sie werden ein anderer
mensch das kann ganz harmlos sein man
hat plötzlich eine neue angewohnheit zum
beispiel spielt man plötzlich mit gummis
rum oder man wird von einem auf den
anderen tag zickig oder melancholisch
oder oder oder
das heißt unsere persönlichkeit würde
gar nicht in unserem gehirn wohnen
sondern in unserem ganzen körper in
jeder zelle
wir wären eine ja quasi holografische
persönlichkeit
mein bruder hatte davor angst ein
anderer mensch zu werden
da ist er lieber nach 30 jahren an der
maschine gestorben eine unglaubliche
entscheidung und eine etwas irritierende
vorstellung die dahintersteckt wir sind
nur die summe unserer teile tauschen wir
sie aus verändern wir uns zurück zu den
clown am ende des tages kommt es also
vielleicht nicht auf ähnlichkeit sondern
auf eine stetige verbindung an auf
kontinuität das würde auch wieder für
die transplantation theorie sprechen
wenn es nur um ähnlichkeit geht dann ist
der clown in berlin ich denn er ist
exakt identisch zu mir aber nur weil
dieser haufen atome genauso angeordnet
ist wie ich muss er ja nicht mit mir zu
tun haben mit mir als ich fünf jahre alt
war habe ich fast nichts mehr gemeinsam
und ich weiß auch kaum noch etwas von
meinem damaligen leben aber trotzdem bin
dass ich oder zumindest war das wahrlich
ein mensch ist keine hülle für ein
gehirn und auch kein fester datensatz
den man kopieren kann sondern vielmehr
ein laufender prozess mit daten die
ständig erneuert und überschrieben
werden
dein körper dein gehirn und deine
gedanken ändern sich ständig sie
verbessern oder verschlechtern sich sie
entwickeln sich weiter und damit ändert
sich auch ständig wer
du bist hier sollten wir überlegen was
für konsequenzen das für unser leben hat
sollten wir etwas an unserem leben
verändern
leben wir richtig ich bin mir auch über
diese konsequenzen unsicher mein bruder
hat sie gezogen das war tragisch ein
unglaublich spannendes thema zum
kopfzerbrechen
wenn ihr mehr über euer gehirn erfahren
wollt dann kommt hier zum video was ist
angst zu rap und zum blog geht es wie
immer hier unten und was meint ihr also
übrigens allerdings natürlich der video
beschreibung welche theorie haltet ihr
für sinnvoll und was macht ihrer meinung
nach aus schreibt es wie immer unten in
die kommentare und ansonst natürlich bis
dann bleib dran